We've got some breaking news here on CBS Sports HQ regarding the World Cup.
So, Germany win but lose.
That's because Germany beat Los Ticos, Costa Rica, 4 - 2.
However, Japan, down a goal against Spain...
...come back to score two in the second half to win 2 - 1...
...and with those results, taking a look at the Group E table,...
...the Blue Samurai will move on with six points.
Spain, although losing to Japan, do qualify for the knockout stage...
...because of goal differential superior to Germany.
And for Germany, a team that are multiple World Cup winners,...
...Kai Havertz had a double in that 4 - 2 victory.
However, two straight World Cup exits before the Round of 16 for the Germans.